PROLOGO - We have three doctors visiting us today from Muhimbili Hospital in Tanzania
as part of a program called Road to IR.
NARRATOR - The United States and developed nations use interventional radiology (or IR) routinely.
Developing countries, however, like Tanzania, have lagged in incorporating
this cutting-edge life-saving technology into their healthcare systems.
But Emory doctors like David Prologo are now working with Yale University's
Tanzania Interventional Radiology Initiative to get physicians in East Africa up to speed.
RUKUNDO - There is no single, trained IR (interventional radiologist) practicing in Tanzania.
So this is how big the need is.
PROLOGO - So they are the first three doctors on the ground in Tanzania
performing minimally invasive interventional radiology procedures and they now are going to form
an education program to teach the next generation. So this is a birth of a subspecialty in East Africa
that we take for granted here in the United States.
NARRATOR - IR is a minimally invasive imaging procedure that allows doctors to diagnose disease
or apply targeted therapy using a
real-time x-ray to enhance precision.
The Tanzanian doctors tell us the technique will be a game-changer in their country,
like it was for the patient who would
have died without the intervention today.
AWADH - He's back to work, he's doing well, he has no complaints at all, so that was like amazing.
MBUGUJE - We are aiming to do complicated procedures by 2021.
NARRATOR - In addition to oversight from seasoned interventional radiologists,
the project will also require funding to help build the infrastructure.
PROLOGO - We don't need financial support to send us over there. We've already got the talent, insight and intelligence in place there.
We need financial support to buy equipment
and build a self-sustaining machine over
there. Because if they can teach the next generation,
and we have the equipment there to perform the procedures, then it
will run on its own, and so many patients
in need of care will be helped.